uh cyprus checking me out on the bootleg
cave podcast
bootleg cat podcast special guest we got
my guy cypress moreno in the building
welcome thanks for having me welcome man
uh congrats you just dropped the new uh
is it ep it's a mix mixtape yeah is it a
mixtape if it's on the dsps yeah i don't
know bro it's a 2021 mixtape okay i
don't know is it on that piff too it's
not so is it a mixtape
that you got a good point you got a good
point
you know called tapped in tapped in now
you have you've been playing me some
music that is not out um you you have
some really big like you i feel like
you've been holding on to music you know
some people they overthink [ __ ] they
hold on to [ __ ] too long and i feel like
you are a very very very uh perfect
example of that because you played me
some [ __ ] then i'm like bro what are you
doing i put this [ __ ] out like
big names like you know what i'm saying
like what was what was it about this
project that like made the timing right
for you to put something out it just
finally felt right
um i kind of set the deadline too i said
it for the 31st so the last day of the
year
but um we're here now in 2022 and yeah
it's going to be a big year cash 22 is a
label so and you've been killing it on
the beats too man i appreciate that
getting a lot of big placements been
producing for a lot of artists all over
the place i mean you played me some [ __ ]
from the homie from detroit that was
crazy would you like sample eminem yeah
we replayed it though shout out coyote
yeah um
for people who don't know what is like
who is cypress moreno what do you do man
i know you like where are you from give
us the whole back story bro i'm a dj i'm
a dj first so
my name is cypress from la dj producer
now i'm you know really focused on the
producing mm-hmm but um
we could i mean [ __ ] we could sit here
and talk for a long time i i'm almost
twenty years i'm almost 10 years in the
game so it started like
it started a while ago i've been i've
been in this l.a [ __ ]
and um it's taken me around the world
i mean you had told me that originally
you were going to college in arizona
right yeah was it tucson tuesday so you
were going to u of a u of a so was what
were you always making music like and
and it was just in the background and
but you were also trying to get a degree
in like you know doing normal [ __ ] like
or was it like something that like what
was what was the catalyst that made you
go full time with this [ __ ] i was a
student athlete i played football in
high school so um
senior year is when like i started djing
just after football season that like sec
what is the second yeah second quarter
second semester right um
this was before i went off to college
college is when i like started really
like turning up parties and [ __ ] were
you playing football u of a nah i wanted
to walk on though
i didn't get a chance to but i was only
there uh there for one
one year but um yeah u of a that's when
i i really started kind of just turning
parties up
um i already had like that connection
back back home with like charisma um
young california amen yep and that like
kind of
kind of came up under that umbrella as
well um when i was in l.a when i got
back from college but yeah it really
started
senior year just you know
i've been around turntables been around
like a couple of djs in the family but
like it wasn't until senior year when i
really like was like all right yeah i'm
really [ __ ] with this i i wasn't
playing sports i had a lot of time with
my hands so you kind of just dove into
djing initially not even beats
necessarily
yeah straight into djing
because like it's like obviously a
probably pretty easy transition to make
but
i think so like if you understand the dj
you understand music if you understand
how to blend records like you know tempo
all that [ __ ] i feel like it makes the
beat making process that much easier i'm
sure most definitely um so you get back
from college that didn't work out what
were we going to college for
uh pre-physiology i don't even know what
that is yeah just
similar to anatomy and
i want to become an athletic trainer oh
that's fire yeah so you're a very smart
guy
we could say that one year at college
was a year more than i had so
yeah
i did a little more school though when i
got back i actually went to recording
school so like okay so you learn how to
engineer and a little bit of that it
really i took the um production program
so it really taught me like the
fundamentals and um music theory that's
really what i got for me
i remember
i went to one of those in a z and i felt
like oh it was like a bunch of aspiring
local rappers that took that class
nah yeah i met a lot of a lot of people
in school yeah uh rappers so when
because like
you know i feel like you really started
to kind of get like a
you know you've been putting in work but
i feel like
when shoreline started to kind of take
off
you were there dj
and
i feel like your wave really kind of
started to blow up just in general
because i feel like you kind of
co-signed and we're kind of behind a lot
of this early
la [ __ ] that we kind of everyone knows
now but you know
you know when me and head would be
talking about like the la [ __ ] like
you were the name that was always coming
up like you and vic you know what i'm
saying as far as like some of the the
early names that were like co-signing
guys like draco and you know shoreline
[ __ ] like that but like
what was like the first like look that
happened for you in this music [ __ ] out
here in la that really kind of
solidified you you think or you felt
like oh this [ __ ] is actually working i
might actually be able to like make a
career out of this like that young
california co-sign
yeah because at a point in time shout
out to amen shout out charisma that was
like way before even that era right just
having like that little yeah at peak
young california is a big deal
most definitely yeah definitely
yeah that was like probably i mean was
this like a
john hart there was like a young
california sound loki it was like john
hart like sage like for sure bobby
brackens late to the basic yeah for sure
for sure now that's real like who was it
from young california that originally
had tapped in with you charisma
um was it originally like back in the
day we was in the club scene and like a
lot of the dj's that kind of like
i guess guided me i could say like in
the right direction
um a couple names marky mark one more dj
knight train charisma was among that
group uh empire element
i think was the name of the club
hollywood like a little 18 and over
where we just all kind of linked up and
yeah from there young california cosign
and
and then
that was really like the beginning of
[ __ ] you know what i liked about you was
that
you made your own lane
instead of having to like because you
know the hollywood dj politics and
trying to get into these clubs and then
the undercutting and to be honest like
as much as people think la clubs pay
great they pay all right bro
i love going to phoenix yeah you go to
like any other city i go to san diego
and get a bag you know everything go to
az or whatever but i feel like you
didn't like a lot of dj's kind of
base their self-worth on that world like
yo i'm at nightingdale or
whatever the [ __ ] right no but i feel
like you just said
hey this is if if
if it comes with it cool but you kind of
just carved your own [ __ ] out yeah now i
always kind of had like this i guess
this vision in the back of my mind
like to do what i'm doing right now like
i always wanted to do i just needed to
learn how to do it um
but it was a djing that really
just it exposed me to you know this
whole music game just different sides
because through that like the young
california umbrella i was doing [ __ ]
like this like i was doing sit down
interviews and trying to do like the
the radio and uh and podcast things like
like yeah like a couple years ago
seven eight years ago
a couple
yeah
that's crazy you've been doing this for
so long you've been doing this for a
minute you look very young bro good
looking you age gracefully
um
so what what was um tell me about man
some of those early days being around
shoreline and just some of those tours
some of those moments man what's like
crazy moments um
because everybody was on that first tour
i didn't just dj for shoreline what was
on that tour rochi one take kailyn
um
literally everybody
yeah uh chike
um
[ __ ] i don't know i gotta look at my my
serato because i got like all these
different crates i just
over the years they just pop it was the
tk baron tour
like y'all managing you you're on the
[ __ ] tour
pretty much pretty much yeah um there's
a lot of people on that tour there's a
lot of people from atlanta uh madman
savage so were you djing like the whole
set bro the whole [ __ ] thing
i was stugging it wow that's stunning no
energy's real
you was like so you were playing
everyone's [ __ ] music yeah oh yeah
that's rough
yeah when i was on tour
i was playing everybody's music
i had i was like
producing while we was on the road i
have a lot of music from like being on
the road but
when i was on tour i guess during that
time i didn't really have a lot of music
out
um
i only had like one song that came out
of that that little area right it's
called sweater guy it's like a
detroit l.a
banger
but
but yeah
[ __ ] crazy moments
was the um
like the guys in the group not getting
along was that like a pretty early on
thing on the tour because i know when
like we talked to jeezy about it like it
felt like he said that like some of that
stuff kind of started to like get
magnified while they were on the road
together yeah we did like i think two
tours together mm-hmm
but not from from from the jump that
[ __ ] was she was lit but i just mean
like we're like like
did you notice like any dysfunction
within like between the homies like
during the during the tours during the
tours yeah
definitely i feel like when you're on
tour with somebody like if you don't
[ __ ] if like if you don't get along with
somebody it's gonna just it's gonna just
oh it could be anything because you
can't escape somebody like yeah we're on
the road together we're in a [ __ ] bus
or we're in a very tight space you know
what i'm saying yeah we have to go to
the next date if we all want to get paid
attention i mean it had it's ups and
downs they had like this right his
moments that [ __ ] was dope
what um because i know you still dj for
like who do you dj for right now
[ __ ] really whoever um hit me up
but
most recently i was at rolling loud with
i did the first day with phoenix
second day with um capollo he's from the
bay yeah
um
and
oh one take one take jay but [ __ ]
i'll really just be
dj for whoever hit me who was on uh
tapped in yo stopping the interview got
to tell you about our good folks at odd
socks man listen go to odd socks
official dot com use the promo code 20
off save 20 off some of the craziest
socks you know they got the ninja turtle
joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheese it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
i'ma look right now
here we go i got the treasure
i don't want to leave anybody you know
stupid young
on fully the godfather i gotta read it
all the way through i gotta name all
these 20 fools
jiggy the goat white john
is white john mc why judah says the
n-word probably yeah that sounds about
right uh
chuckster kilio
glock boys
i didn't even lie to you bro i feel like
i'm like semi-tapped into what's going
on
and it i would say about 50 of these
artists i don't know which is a good
thing
because i like to discover new artists
yeah we got young global doley bernays
global from hawaii doli from new york
um how do you tap in with someone from
hawaii
[ __ ] just going out in hawaii
having a show in hawaii being drunk
just
ballerinas you ever heard of ballerinas
is it hawaii yeah nah strip club maybe
going to is it strip club yeah it's
where is it honolulu though honolulu
i've only been to maui
yeah honolulu hawaiians
that's oahu or that's the main yeah
that's the main island hawaiian strip
club gotta be a movie though if it's all
hawaiian women because white women are
so beautiful it's cool it's gotta be a
vibe it's a good time what's your they
show
every city outside of l.a what's your
favorite city to like
party in to like go to like that you get
the most love you think
atlanta's fun atlanta culture
great food good food um good scene
let me see
i'm not like the
even though i come from a big city in
new york i can only do it like for so
long oh yeah new york is it becomes a
lot faster it's cool though like i like
working in new york yeah now new york is
cool but it's like small doses you there
for a reason yeah new york i got people
who live there god bless them
they got
they got a whole entire
like they could withstand walking in
subways and people more than i can i
really i mean [ __ ] i [ __ ] with arizona
yeah you went to school there yeah yeah
phoenix is cool too phoenix is a vibe
yeah you always i feel like you're
always doing after parties in phoenix
yeah i like some random place yeah for
sure like damn they got cyprus and where
the [ __ ] is here i gotta look this place
up i'll pull up man i'll be showing lips
whoever shows love to me um you're very
good at like kind of spotting like new
talent who are some of the newer artists
um that that you think that we haven't
kind of like you know
discovered yet that you kind of you got
your eye on bro
um right now
i say like everybody on tapped in for
real everybody on the project everybody
on the project just you know from from
drake all the way all the way down
um but
i'm listening to like a lot of like
what's going on in san diego right now
like recently i just been what's going
on let me know what's going on because i
be in san diego a lot i don't know
what's going on there but i got a lot of
hispanic rappers okay on one and then
it's a lot of dudes bubbling from the
city little rob
is that where you from he's from san
diego he's a charger fan
that was from san diego though
oh is he a charger fan i don't know i
would hope so right
i don't know little rob was a legend
charger fans are sick right now oh my
god
are you a charger fan no no
bro they had it they just had to just
let the clock run out they would have
both been in the playoffs
whoever that coach is that would have
been crazy
i don't know he had a chip in his
shoulder i didn't really get that they
got to fire that coach you think so of
cour bro did you watch the game yeah
that fourth in like [ __ ] four on
their own 18.
terrible call
they gave the ball a break there's a
whole lot going on during that game
like the commentators
the whole situation like somebody may
have i guess they could have ended what
ben's career
if it would have been yeah yeah if they
would have tied both would have got in
and ben would have and they steelers
were out okay so i was kind of hoping
for the ties [ __ ] rothersburg anyway
um what about like as far as like uh you
know
i see you got the weed here you got the
label are you like signing an artist too
are you are you like actively looking
for artists to sign uh yeah definitely
i'm gonna i want to get to that point
where i got a you know a couple artists
have you done that do you have any yet
or you're still not right now i'm like
the artist the producer so you're just
kind of making sure you got a uh imprint
to release your own [ __ ] through right
now you build it up no cash went through
the label like
started it in 2018.
um this was actually my second full i
guess full body of work um i put a
project out with big sad that was
through cash 22 1900.
what's up with um i know you have
a domain project you've been working on
are there any other projects that you
have just been kind of working on like
full collaborative yeah with artists
that's it pretty much
almost finished up
it's a lot of coyotes
they're dope yeah i got some crazy [ __ ]
with them who else i'd have to look to
my phone it's a game it's a gang of
little eps and yeah full-length products
are they ever gonna come out though
this year okay it's 2022. you gotta like
you said when you when you literally say
man there's a whole lot on my phone i
was i can't even knit i just i just hope
this [ __ ] comes out it's right here
it's right here so what's coming out
next what's coming out next
um
who knows
it's it's a couple single like some of
the homies are putting putting out stuff
that i produce okay shout out west side
where i got a
song with him called fake hustle fake
hustle yeah okay banger um that's coming
out
and a couple singles
it's just
i i really gotta look
yo uh but 2022 kind of like already
it's already like the blueprint is
already kind of written you were talking
about some of the mexican artists that
are in san diego we talked about the
the full community put out their their
list of the top mexican rappers who's
your top five mexican rappers right now
mexican rappers right now right now
um
they don't even got to be like who's the
biggest just who who are you who do you
like you want that food community club
you want to
i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
shout out to them but i guess all the
homies i got music with people that i
got i'm trying to think all the mexican
rapper robbers i got music with you
mentioned the coyotes
yeah
i got some [ __ ] well jeezy
um who else is mexican
little maru
pretty sure yeah i think he's mexican
san diego
um
one more then
bravo bravo mexican yeah probably the
back chaser that i'm not sure about
as a white man i can't just be guessing
people's ethnicities in 2022.
they'll put they'll be like
what because what if he's not and
you know
yeah all right well look man the project
is out yeah project is out man shot
everybody involved videos coming
yeah i dropped one um well the one to
the single on no jumper up the score
that [ __ ] out right now
um
i dropped one to the intro featuring
young global endoli no limit that one's
out
and i just dropped a video with kaylin
too caitlyn for real for real it was a
single that we put out last year called
call me yo i wanted to ask you two
before we get out of here what what like
like obviously
the loss of draco
rest in peace draco um
you know for people who aren't in la who
don't kind of understand like the
gravity of like how big he was in the
city like
um obviously somebody who you were close
with but like
what was that day like because i
remember finding out and being like [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] was crazy that she was a
trip um
yeah that shoots a trip were you at that
show at all nah so i was at rolling loud
the week before
so just being that rolling loud and
experiencing three days rolling level
two because like the rolling loud
protocols they changed completely
i don't know if they knew that kanye was
coming beforehand they probably did but
right they was on some [ __ ] bro like
security wise
um
which i'm looking back on and i'm like
okay yeah
i could see how nothing really happened
at rolling loud the way they was it was
really like
[ __ ] the way we was escorted it was just
a trip everything was on point
calculated so
me being fresh from wrong and loud and
kind of like you know the festivals
been
that was that was a big festival don't
get me wrong that learned to look dope
definitely wanted to be there but at the
same time i was just kind of whooped
from wrong and loud oh yeah you spent
three days rolling around yeah three
down for the rest of the year you know
commuting to the ie so i'm just thinking
like i'm finna deal with security you
know just cover it go get the covert
wristband lines walking
can't get in the ubers i'm just thinking
yeah
you know this is right down the street
am i really missing out
kind of watching everything from you
know from the stories right and then
you know that [ __ ] was a trip because i
had two passes to pull up i was thinking
like i might pull up around 7 p.m to go
check out like you know
i think it was draco
uh 50 cent and snoop or it was like a
couple people i don't know watch just on
some regular [ __ ] but no that [ __ ] was a
trip that day was crazy yeah like can
you kind of try to put in the words in
your opinion like what what what draco
meant in l.a you know what i'm saying
for people who don't know he just
created the whole
i wouldn't say he created the whole
new way but he was a huge part of it it
was a huge art
yeah they influenced a lot of like the
rappers that are doing [ __ ] ryan i feel
like am greedo like you know there's a
few of those guys that like
i feel like he was finally starting to
get some of that credit you know what
i'm saying yeah so yeah rest in peace to
draco uh hopefully you got some
a whole busy ass 20 22 for us no i plan
to i plan to man
this year like i plan to you know drop
more music
i've been holding it
for the right moments i feel like the
moments are coming this year there it is
man anything else you want to shout out
you got [ __ ] weed here
man [ __ ] shout out cash 22 cash gallery
la
oh yeah you got the gallery yeah which
is dope so if you ever come into la and
you need to play like a space to like do
a pop-up or
do whatever i mean just tap in at cash
gallery at life what was the uh you was
also kind of running up the little you
know the pandemic strippies you know
what i'm saying how was the pandemic
strip club game no that was cash 22
parties labor parties oh okay okay okay
yeah yeah
oh shout out today we still got i mean
you see you you always more than what we
got to get you to come a dj one actually
let's do it man yeah let's do it i'll do
it for free okay
anyway there it is man shout out my guy
cypress moreno go follow him hey thanks
for having me for real boom